These sharks are growing miniature antibodies
First discovered in camels in the 1980s,
these tiny antibodies--about one half
the size of conventional ones -- are also produced by
sharks, llamas, and a few other animals.
Regular antibodies are made of four protein chains --
2 heavy, 2 light.
Small antibodies are made of just 2 heavy chains.
It’s thought that this super lightweight version
of antibodies has evolved independently several times
suggesting they are highly effective in these animals.
We just don’t know exactly what they are doing.
This hasn’t stopped researchers from using
mini-antibodies, and their useful fragments --
often termed nanobodies --
in clinical and basic science studies.
Nanobodies gained early fame for their role in
helping to visualize the structure of complex proteins.
Their small size lets them bind tightly and deeply --
and this can help stabilize ornate molecules whose
flexibility thwarts the imaging process
Their structure also has the advantage of
letting them function inside of a cell.
It’s a new way for researchers to study
proteins in action--forcing hookups, or blocking them,
or taking targeted molecules out of the game
altogether--as the cell goes about its business.
On the clinical side, researchers are testing nanobodies
and other small antibodies in the fight against diseases
from lupus to lung
fibrosis.
One holdup has been the llamas and the sharks.
In order to get nanobodies tailored
to a specific molecule, the molecule must
be first injected into the animals.
The animals then make small antibodies
over the course of weeks or months.
Researchers use blood cells from the animals
to obtain genes for the small antibodies and
then use bacteria to produce the nanobodies in the lab.
But it might soon be easier to obtain nanobodies--
a team has made a nanobody library in yeast cells
that will allow researchers to
skip the animal-inoculation step.
Next on the horizon for nanobodies--
getting them to stick to tumors for imaging purposes
and using them to allow drugs to cross the
blood-brain barrier to tackle diseases of the brain.